we're back with the cast and scream all
right let's get to some super scream
fans for a little
druid day
all right we're gonna take a look at a
quick clip um that's actually related to
this take a look
so you got a boyfriend
why you want to ask me out on a date
maybe
do you have a boyfriend
no you never told me your name
why do you want to know my name i want
to know who i'm looking at
what did you say
all right corey and sean what's your
question
[Applause]
i don't know if you can see but i made
this shirt for you courtney it says gays
love gail weathers
i love that
um well like
that scene is so iconic and this movie
is so iconic i was wondering like
was there ever a moment that when you
were filming that you just sat back it
was like wow we really just created
something so
iconic that will stand the test of time
um i i think there there was no way to
know that that these films would would
have this kind of a a life um i think
as i said earlier i think we had a sense
of lightning in a bottle but to know
that they would last 25 years and that
millions of people would be uber fans
and that you know we'd see our faces
tattooed on people's legs which has
happened many times
um there's no way to comprehend that
thank you corey and sean
thank you for wearing your courtney cox
sweatshirt
okay let's take a quick look at another
iconic scene that a fan has a question
about
what's up knife what happened are you
all right she's not answering any
questions all right just leave us alone
no no tatum it's okay she's just doing
her job right kim yes that's right
so how's the book
well it'll be out later this year oh
i'll look for it
i'll send you a copy
hi guys um so my question is for uh
nevin courtney your characters seriously
uh kick butt and including each other at
times uh but who would win in a fight
between gail sydney and
laurie strode aka jamie lee curtis and
halloween
i think it would have to go down between
you and jamie because i'd be out somehow
i'd be putting lipstick on and
something somebody would just
slash me i think i got to give it to
laurie really oh my well i mean jamie
lee come on she's such she's an
incredible incredible woman and yeah
thank you guys so much thank you
stephanie
okay we're gonna take a look at our next
clip related to our next question
there's a formula to it a very simple
formula everybody's a suspect
telling you the dad's a red herring it's
billy
how do we know you're not the killer
huh
huh hi billy
um this fan is on zoom hi what's your
question
do you think the character of randy died
too soon
for sure of course
we'd all love to have randy back
randy is funny do you mind taking off
your masks sir
[Applause]
sorry guys i didn't i didn't get to
shave yet
that's good
jamie
jamie will you tell us one thing about
your scream experience that nobody might
know give us a fly on the wall memory
i was always the fifth wheel the third
wheel uh
after uh the
me and nev and matthew went to uh the
city together and uh champagne supernova
remember that nav
and uh we were always listening to oasis
and you guys had a
budding thing and um
courtney and david i don't know if you
remember the table read but after we
shared a limo at the airport together
and
let's just say you guys were you know
had your own part of the limo and i was
over here
boy drew you asked for something no one
knew there you go and here we are 25
years later jamie thank you so much for
being here
thank you thank you thank you
okay more with the cast of scream my
fellow friends right after the break
[Music]